ein wundervoller morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer wunderschönen kleinen
minecraft welt was nicht so schön ist es
dass hier
ich habe meine augen lizenz sondern das
was uns allerdings nicht vom heutigen
plan abhalten meine lieben freunde denn
ich habe es ja bereits in der letzten
folge angekündigt ich baue heute mein
traumhaus
[Musik]
was sind das für geräusche das ist das
was ist das englische gabeln werden doch
nicht geworfen
von rüdiger was ist denn das würde misst
und läutet wächst hier der geht mir
allerdings wirklich am rat vorbei meine
lieben freunde denn wir müssen erstmal
zu der anderen insel da hinten fahren
denn wir benötigen wir benötigen nämlich
ein bisschen ton und sand und sand gibt
es hier vorne und ich hoffe jetzt
einfach mal dass da auch irgendwie klar
ist also ton denn den brauchen wir
wiederum für blumen
[Musik]
gerade ein piratenschiff gefunden ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich vertraue dem braten
noch nicht so ganz so wie ich meine
minecraft welt kenne kommt er jeden
moment irgendwie ein dings rausgefahren
und pirat auf seinem kleinen brötchen
und macht und so was von die hucke voll
ich wäre euch sehr dankbar wenn ihr
jetzt schon mal unten in die kommentare
schreiben würde wenn ihr irgendwelche
tipps habt für das piratenschiff und
dementsprechend für die nächste folge
weil nicht dass ich daran irgendwie ohne
rüstung reingehe oder keine ahnung was
und dann stelle ich mir nicht so gut
aber auch nichts neues viele haben mir
auch immer wieder den kommentare
geschrieben hey luca wann machst du denn
mal die bootstour das mal so ein
bisschen eine welt entdeckt weil ich
meine ist träger natürlich schon krass
wenn man am horizont dann irgendwie
sowas sieht oder beispielsweise das
piratenschiff dahinten ich will es jetzt
allerdings nicht direkt zu beginn des
projekts machen wisst ihr wie ich meinen
so ich hätte ja gesagt dass wir das
vielleicht in der übernächsten folge
dann mal machen oder so also heute
konzentrieren wir uns wirklich wirklich
auf mein haus ich habe damit noch gar
nicht angefangen bin der aufnahmen jetzt
schon bei minute 15 ist wieder richtig
schön hier
[Musik]
ich war dass die sonne untergeht und
dann gehe ich schlafen richtig
[Musik]
der wollte mich eigentlich alle
verarschen und jetzt würde ich sagen
meine time labs und ich suche mir alle
sachen zusammen die ich für mein
traumhaus brauche da das mit den
ressourcen sammeln ein bisschen länger
gedauert haben habe ich mir gedacht
erzähle ich euch einfach mal einen
kurzen witz wären die time labs läuft
und zwar haben sich fred und klaus wie
üblich am dienstagabend getroffen um
über ihre schandtaten vom letzten
wochenende zu reden fred hat daraufhin
geprallt ich war am wochenende auf einer
party und die war so krank die gastgeber
hatten sogar ein goldenes klo daraufhin
meinte klaus weise in goldenes klo nach
einigem hin und her kamen die beiden
dann auf die idee einfach mal den leuten
die diese party geschmissen haben einen
besuch abzustatten und nachzusehen ob
das mit dem goldenen pro auch
tatsächlich gestimmt hat gesagt getan
die beiden marschierten los und kamen
einige zeit später in dem haus an wo die
party stattgefunden hat eine etwas
ältere frau hat die tür darauf hin
geöffnet und gefragt kann ich ihnen
helfen
daraufhin meinte fred jaggi ledige frau
ich war hier am wochenende auf ihrer
party und mein freund klaus hier
der will nicht glauben dass sie hier im
haus ein goldenes klo haben daraufhin
hat die frau die beiden angeguckt sich
zu ihrem hausflur umgedreht und zu ihrem
mann gerufen hermann hier ist das
schwein das in deine trompete gepackt
hat
das hat jetzt 20 minuten gedauert und
vielleicht habe ich zuletzt gesehen ich
bin währenddessen auch kurz nach da
hinten gefahren um nur ein paar bäume ab
zu fällen das war jetzt keine krass
große insel die ich hab dich erkundet
habe sondern ich brauchte holz und ich
wollte dafür jetzt nicht meine bäume
hätten obwohl ich den hier trotzdem
leider auch noch zerpflücken muss doch
die sache ist allerdings und das betrübt
mich so ein bisschen
irgendwann möchte ich natürlich auch
dinge verzaubern und um sachen gut
verzaubern zu können braucht man einen
enchantment table also einen zauber
tisch und das hat das problem dass man
dafür bücher benötigt und für bücher
benötigt man leder und lieder bekommt
man nur wenn man tiere tötet die kuh
nicht dich ja plötzlich hat es mich
liebt 1 du stehst im weg bis 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 und dir ich doch 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
dann müssen der ihr steht alle im weg
herum hier hoch hier hoch hier hoch
genau hier in 23 freilassen hier sack
dann hier auch noch am baum soll jetzt
die ganze zeit ihren allerdings gucken
muss aber ich habe hier mein haus
schauen war vorgezeichnet ich weiß ich
bin irgendwie zu motiviert für dieses
projekt
[Musik]
ja das muss ich jetzt mal wegräumen obst
[Applaus]
hier vorne sollen auf jeden fall eine
treppe hindi soll dann hier so hoch
gehen sagt denn eigentlich möchte ich
oben leben ich finde das immer irgendwie
so ein bisschen schöner als wenn man
dann irgendwie ich finde das irgendwie
ein bisschen schöner weil man dann auch
in besseren ausblick hat und so weiter
und so fort und das ist mir persönlich
wirklich immer sehr wichtig so jetzt
brauchen wir hier vorne die rechen
stimme davon kommen nämlich 123 hier in
die höhe
hier vorne auch 123 hier vorne 12 wo ich
endlich dabei wird könnt ihr euch eine
kleine geschichte erzählen und zwar
handelt diese geschichte von dem kleinen
luca der mal im sommer urlaub mit seiner
familie an der nordsee war und dort an
der nordsee gab es ein
spielwarengeschäft oder spielzeugladen
wie auch immer man es nennen mag und in
diesem spielzeugladen gab es einen bei
oracle den so hat es mir zumindest
seinen eltern verkauft essen wirklich
nur dort gab aber nur weil luca ihn
unbedingt haben wollte und da war dann
wiederum das ding dass lucas eltern
gesagt haben okay
es ist zwar erst demnächst weihnachten
bla bla bla bla bla
allerdings kaufen wir ihnen die wirklich
jetzt schon und dann hat luca den
bekommen und war total happy und lucas
eltern happy und ein paar tage später
hat lukas papa dann herausgefunden da
gab's halt noch nicht so richtig dass
mit dem internet das man kurz mit dem
smartphone gegoogelt hat ob sie nehmen
wo günstiger gibt oder so lukas papa
dann auf jeden fall herausgefunden
mensch ich hab mich verbaute gab mir
kannst du sowas nicht geben werde ich
mich dann kurz aufeinander ware
konzentriere auf jeden fall haben lucas
eltern mitbekommen das ist diesen
gameboy wäre sich lucas eltern haben auf
jeden fall mit bekommen das diese moral
von der geschicht lucas eltern haben
mitbekommen dass luca hatte sich das nur
ausgedacht hat damit er früher den
gameboy haben darf was es geht
wir können doch mal ganz kurz eben die
farm hier vorne entleeren das ist ja
ordentlich gewachsen hier vorne dann
sieht jetzt mal dass das alles hier
super funktioniert also ich drück drauf
alles wird abgemäht ich kann reingehen
das wasser ist wieder drin
lauf hier einmal durch und jetzt können
wir ja gleich mal kurz schauen wie viel
reisen ja ich bin völlig lost heute ich
habe dadurch jetzt tatsächlich mehr als
113 sammeln können von daher bepflanzt
sich jetzt mal alles kurz neu auf jeden
fall war es so dass meine eltern das
herausgefunden haben dass der kleine
luca das natürlich nur gesagt habe damit
er diesen bionic indirekt schon haben
darf und haben ihnen daraufhin
weggenommen wieder zurück gegeben bei
dem laden und kleinen luca war daraufhin
sambuca hatte gar kein rechter zu sauer
zu sein aber ihr kennt das
wahrscheinlich wenn ihr irgendwie stress
mit euren eltern haben und ihr wisst ihr
seitdem unrecht an wollte trotzdem ich
nachgeben
so war es auf jeden fall bei mir immer
und luca hat daraufhin mit seiner mutter
nicht mehr geredet für einen gewissen
zeitraum und lukas mama dann auch nicht
mehr mit ihm geredet und als das die
ganze zeit so weiterginge und luca
gesehen hat dass er damit nicht so
richtig zum ziel kommt hat er seiner
mutter ein bild gemalt
[Musik]
und dieses bild kann ich euch jetzt mal
kurz einblenden
darauf steht nämlich friede dann einen
regenbogen keine ahnung welchen
regenbogen die farbe braun vorkommens
und darunter habe ich geschrieben
entschuldigung liebe mama aber du musst
dich auch entschuldigen
ja danach wollen wir wieder freunde und
das war die geschichte vom kleinen luca
und dem bajonett
hier geht's jetzt allerdings mit unserem
kleinen häuschen weiter ich glaube ihr
seht schon so ein bisschen in welche
richtung es hier geht und zwar möchte
ich so ein kleines farm häuschen machen
man kann nie genug zu essen haben finde
ich das ist auch in real life ansicht
von ihrem ich möchte vorne auf jeden
fall so eine kleine innen liegende paar
machen finde ich glaube ich ganz schön
ich glaube ich werde die nicht ernten so
dass das einfach immer so ein bisschen
schön beliebt aussieht und so weiter und
so fort hier vorne die türen so dann
brauchen wir natürlich auch noch den
stein ziegelboden das hier soll so ein
bisschen mein lager werden für die
ganzen weizen sachen das fand ich mich
ganz schön wenn hier das feld ist das
hier das lager und da hinten ist quasi
unser richtiges feld von daher brauchen
wir dafür ein paar fässer und damit ein
bisschen schöner aussieht habe ich mich
extra noch informiert wie man
blumentöpfe macht der profi hier rein
fast hin und hier vorne ein fast hin
hier werde ich eine laterne drauf setzte
mit wie ein bisschen beleuchtung haben
und hier einen blumentopf mit einem
löwenzahn drin hier kommt auch noch
einen knopf dran das war nicht ganz
schön hier die laterne hier vorne auch
noch eine laterne
ich habe natürlich inspirationen
beziehen wir nicht nur inspiration das
haus kann man quasi 19 auf youtube
finden dann nehmen wir schon mal die
glasscheiben dann kann ich euch schon
mal zeigen dass ich mich hier vorne eine
komplette glasscheibe hinkommt damit wir
auch unser feld und unsere ganze insel
begutachten können hier kommen
glasscheiben hin hier vorne machen wir
das so hier kommt nämlich auch noch eine
glasscheibe hin
dann nehmen wir uns die eichen
holzbretter machen das hier so fertig
ich weiß gar nicht ob es gerade spannend
ist für euch sich das hier anzuschauen
oder zuzuhören whatever allerdings ja
nichts allerdings ist muss halt sein wir
brauchen ein haus hier vorne kommt jetzt
ein kleines ab dahin auch die nicht so
scheiße auch hier vorne an die seite
kommt übrigens erde die muss ich
allerdings glaube ich hier mit der erde
verbinden damit die grün wird hier oben
denn ich möchte dass dort so ein paar
blüten wachsen an der seite dann mache
ich nachher noch falltüren dran damit
das auch so richtig schön alles über
wächst und hier vorne möchte ich genau
das gleiche machen also hier fünf erde
hin
dann brauche ich hier quasi so eine
kleine treppe dass das ja alles noch ein
bisschen mit dem gras verliert wir gehen
allerdings wieder nach oben und bauen
unser dach ein wenig weiter wir müssen
jetzt so reichen holztreppen dran das
sieht glaube ich ganz schön aus und muss
ich noch immer kurz ihr zur seite gehen
aber gut hier kommt auf jeden fall dann
so ein bisschen begrünung hin ein
bisschen finanzen das machen wir dann in
der nächsten folge
hier unten ist auf jeden fall alles
fertig also hier kann man reingehen hier
sind denn die ganzen weizen sachen und
so oben geht noch ein bisschen was hier
oben habe ich mir das nämlich so
vorgestellt das hier vorne zwei öfen
sind dann die werkbank hier
da nehmen doch die fässer da kommt
nämlich hier vorne 1 hin und hier neben
das bett kommen auch zwei übereinander
eine laterne stelle ich dann
beispielsweise hierhin und hier oben
drauf noch eine jeden ein blumentopf mit
und läutet bei nexteer der blumentopf
auf die werkbank mit einem stück mohn
drinnen und dann hier alles ein bisschen
mit falltüren so dass das so ein
bisschen abgetrennt aussieht hier vorne
nämlich auch zack zack
wie das so alles ganz schön aus
fallschirm kommen übrigens auch hier
vorne ich weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt
schon machen kann oder ob das dann nicht
zu groß wird weil das gebiet überhaupt
nicht zu gras was sollen das hier das
geht gar nicht dass hier vorne komme
hier geht s richtig voran ist hier auch
irgendwie wettbewerbsverzerrung die
teile sollen auf jeden fall hier vorne
dran damit dass ihr so ein bisschen
abgetrennt aussieht wissen wie ich meine
ich dachte ich das geht schneller hier
sind schon anderthalb stunden kurz eine
verordnung sorgen die kisten möchte ich
nämlich hier vorne hinsetzen zwei über
100 warum verbinden die sich nicht so
zwei übereinander hier auf jeden fall
hier oben ist es dann schon mehr oder
weniger fertig hier soll halt noch so
ein teppich rhein in weißer wurde die
sache ist nur dass wir dafür eine wurde
fehlt du hast nur fleisch an dir keine
wolle den teppich können wir jetzt hier
vorne so hinlegen dann sieht nämlich
auch so ein bisschen wohnlicher aus und
da also das ist mein haus ich weiß ich
hab jetzt einige vielleicht mehr
erwartet haben aber ich bin jetzt auch
nicht der beste in minecraft ich habe
mir übrigens auch noch ein lagerfeuer
gemacht weil ich mir gedacht habe dass
man das vielleicht irgendwie hier
hinsetzen könnte so und dann wenn man
von unten guckt ich weiß nicht ob das
bei nacht vielleicht ein bisschen
schöner aussieht aber bei tag kann man
das glaube ich auch erkennen na dann
sieht zusätzlich ein schornstein
das ist schon schön oder mit dem
schornstein
hier vorne guckt euch das mal ja du bist
hässlich ich brauche mich jetzt mal so
ein bisschen nach oben und kann man das
vielleicht mal ein bisschen besser sehen
altar das ist richtig schön hier mit dem
haus dann hier vorne mit unserer kleinen
farmen was ich auch noch gedacht habe
was man machen könnte deswegen habe ich
mir direkt zwei lagerfeuer gemacht war
dass man vielleicht irgendwie hier so
und lagerfeuer hinsetzt und dann kann
man sich theoretisch die baumstämme
nehmen und hier so in der art mega ich
dachte das geht nicht da das ist ja wie
ein richtiges feuer ich dachte das macht
er das ist ja ich dachte das wäre nicht
schlimm wenn man dadurch läuft man so
dann können wir hier nämlich jetzt
theoretisch so noch irgendwie so ein
dings nehmen und hier irgendwie so und
damit aus dem hochwald und sieht aus wie
ein sitz lagerfeuer
mir wurde zahlreiche kommentare
geschrieben hey luca du kannst einfach
lagerfeuer hier hinsetzen und die
ausmachen dann sieht das mehr aus wie
ein steak wir haben ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele projekte noch ich will auch dass
hier alles mal aus stein stiegl sein job
ich will diese teile ja steins siegel
stufen machen ich möchte noch ein paar
laternen mit captain von den bäumen
runter hängen lassen
allerdings haben in dieser folge
wirklich wieder extrem viel geschafft
ich musste jetzt das alles noch da oben
rein zu kommen was mach ich noch eben
schnell und barmen hier sind die beiden
kisten auf jeden fall prall gefüllt ich
habe jetzt die fässer noch nicht befüllt
und auch unten habe ich jetzt noch nicht
so richtig sortiert beziehungsweise
generell sortiert hier unten sollte er
so weit in sachen rein und sachen für
die ernte die sache ist allerdings dass
hier an der stelle die heutige wieso
jetzt auch beenden würde ich habe immer
noch ganz ganz viel auf meiner
to-do-liste hier stehen
das schaffen wir heute nicht mehr ich
bin schon bei fast zwei stunden in der
aufnahme muss das jetzt irgendwie runter
schneiden oft 10 15 minuten die lange
xxl folge wird auf jeden fall kommen in
der nächsten folge erkunden wie das
piratenschiff machen noch sonntag sachen
jan der insel ein bisschen insel
reparatur und danach in der übernächsten
folge
da machen wir die fette bootstour ich
sehe euch allerdings erstmal morgen
wieder chelsea
[Musik]